here's what would happen if you were
born on Mars well you'd be a lot
different than you are today Mars only
has one third of the gravity of Earth so
your body wouldn't be experiencing the
same amount of force your bones would
lose their density and become more
brittle on Mars you'd be experiencing a
thin atmosphere with only Trace Amounts
of oxygen you'd have to live underground
or in a thickly insulated house to
survive that harsh atmosphere and since
Mars doesn't have the same types of
bacteria and viruses that the Earth does
be careful if you ever go visit your
relatives on Earth since your immune
system would be weaker than that of an
Earthling on Earth your body produces
melanin to protect you from radiation
but the radiation on Mars is much
stronger instead your skin would produce
carotenoids this pigment would help
protect you against skin cancer by
slowing or stopping the cell cycle but
your skin would turn orange so